what is happening reject nation
magnesites haters who are here
my good friend tyrone magnus has
interviewed
zach snyder i'm really freaking happy
for tyrone this guy since
day one has been a hardcore snyder-verse
supporter there's people such as myself
to give you like a quick
quick example i've always been fond of
men of steel i've always loved it
bvs i'm a late bloomer to really
appreciate in that movie
it's no secret i could easily delete the
videos if i wanted to of the times when
i talk crap on bvs when it first came
out it wasn't until it was definitely
some time before the snyder cut was
officially announced where i really
started to grow a big appreciation for
that film especially with the ultimate
edition where i
really grew in love with that movie so
i'm like
late to being a passionate snyder versus
supporter i've always been in support of
the snyder cut
signed the petition day one that's like
the basic summary version of my
experience with the snyder films and my
point with that though
i'm bringing that up is tyrone never
needed like a bvs
ultimate edition he has always always
always been
enthusiastic supporter true believer of
zack snyder's vision whereas there's
people like me who were a little late to
getting what zack snyder was doing
[ __ ] [ __ ] we're all [ __ ] we
deserve to be shamed
forever and never appreciated for
actually coming around
yeah all right guys what was that
what are you saying oh i'm i'm i'm not
jealous at all
i'm not jealous i don't know why you
already got me exactly
for us let's just watch this
okay i call tyrone immediately after the
reaction she probably teased that
beforehand
what is happening in magnesites so you
all been wondering what the big
announcement was
well i was so excited for some of you
nailed it on the head some of you over
shot
by far no i have not you're starring in
justice league taste is
the green lantern or steel you lied to
me
oh yes one on one zach
snyder the man the snyder man
himself it's a great shot so how zack
snyder's face the entire interview
how excited i was in that one video
where i was running around the room and
acting all crazy
y'all don't even know it just went down
my boy we hit it off
like best friends
it was because when i interviewed this
man
i got a chance to ask him questions
i've been wanting answered since i've
been meaning to even
thought about watching why wasn't i
casting your movie zac
we got along like we was all friends it
just the energy just felt great
did we just become best friends okay
so i want you to watch this i was part
of a press
junket where we all basically waited in
this virtual line
to speak to the man himself and once i
got a chance to
it went great by the way i will be
pinning this to my
facebook fan page and to my twitter
and to my community tag so no excuses
there is
a live event tonight
oh yes sir hosting that will be hosted
on another channel okay zach
will be appearing you will be showing up
i'm going to help host the event
so make sure you are all there 8 p.m
eastern standard time and now without
further ado
interview 5 p.m
sometimes
[Music]
i'm here
awesome how are you i'm good
as a moviegoer i gotta say huge fan and
as an
actor i definitely want to work with you
someday
okay let's go gotta get that out the way
okay so first question is after this
movie is released
and it explodes with popularity when
warner brothers says
we need you back to finish your vision
of the snyder verse
is the snyderman return
look i didn't think i'd be talking to
you right now about the about justice
league so
you know clearly stranger things have
happened
right so i'm just the guy saying
so it's definitely a possibility
never know
now all right
um another question is
many of the fans want to know
did you think about bringing
henry cavill back with long hair and the
beard
with the black suit oh that's a good
question yeah
well we talked about it a lot and i
was a slight advocate um a little bit
for the mullet
but i think that there was no way to go
back from that and at the time the
studio was really leaning on me
pretty hard and uh it was just
i don't i was lucky to be able to figure
it out so i could get the black suit
um you know dj and i had done a lot of
research before
so we knew how to turn the color suit
black because i always said like look
i'll shoot the color soon
but it's a mistake okay
i'm just saying it out loud to you guys
this is [ __ ]
um they were like look like you don't
know what you're talking about no one
wants a black suit
let's just hear the color heads out
black suit looks great
it looks great on my [ __ ] post you
guys are going to
change your mind uh but yeah so anyway
but here we are with the black suit so
um yeah the beard and the long hair
there was just that was gonna be
that's a that was there was no way to
you know to undo that
right right gotcha you can't throw me
you know
we saw how that went last time
he's a badass and that would have went
with the badass
but the fans are very vocal they
understand now
i can look look i'm i love that they
care
about that we we care more than studios
think
now they know um next
you know that i'm a huge fan of the
dynamic
cape florida yes he's asking about it
he's asking about the game plan where
did you get
[Applause]
[Music]
[Laughter]
look in that that just it shoots back to
the todd mcfarlane
comic books for me he had that dynamic
look and yours was like
his look come to life on the screen yeah
you know i guess i
just love i just love a really strong
expressive cape it's got to be flapping
yeah
it's gotta do its thing it's gonna be
fun dj my visual effects supervisor
he also knows so he's always like like
he'll say i didn't even show you that
shot because the cape was lame
it's not a lot and so yeah so i i just
it's just
it's in our dna now we've got to get
that cake yeah
gotcha gotcha that's it thank you very
much for your time
all right i haven't come directly on the
channel this time
next time i can't wait to talk dude all
right we'll do that
we'll do that all right thank you sir
dude that's on record that's
i all recorded do it yo that was great
that was wonderful
wow man congrats that was wonderful
kudos one second let me see if i can
call tyrone
yes
hello tyrone
i'm actually talking with a voice
impersonator right now this is not the
real tyron magnus
[Laughter]
dude dude i know whenever i call you
um we we're on the phone for an hour
that is not going to be the case right
now this is going to be
a one minute phone call i just wanted to
call you super quick
you did great you did so good this is
awesome you asked him about the cape
flappin
like the first question i wanted to ask
i remembered watching that video you did
year i was like wow there's so much is
the most editing i've seen tyrone do in
a video in a long time
it was when you did the the whole thing
with him cape flapping and you were
breaking it down and i remember watching
that going oh my god yeah there's a lot
of cape flapping going on here
yeah man he's appreciate he's
appreciative of a great cake flat man so
you know he he understood what i was
talking about with the whole uh
todd mcfarland look you know what i mean
he always had extravagant cakes and
stuff like that and
his movies were like that like watching
that you know what i mean
he said at the end that he wants he
wants to come directly on your channel
afterwards so you're gonna get more than
four minutes with the guy yeah he
watches me
i know dude that was that was so great
he wants to come on the channel so you
know
i'm on cloud nine man guy's the limit
dude that is awesome because yeah when
you looked at i'm assuming you were
uh shouting to scarlow and not some
other woman
[Laughter]
carlo i was talking too anyone nearby
did
anyone hear me it was the mail man cut
out was he opened the window and just
yelled at the mailman
baby man i loved it like these are my
favorite kind of interviews because you
didn't change your personality
at all like you were literally a hundred
percent i'm like that's that's the man i
know right there
he's just being himself keeping it real
and yeah i think the volume was on 10
for me
i had to try to control the energy
and asking the most important question
without fanboying out
you know people people were
i know that they wanted me to ask
please cast me
not going to corner the man like that of
course
no that's what these things are for that
would have been a little disrespectful
to try to corner him to ask him for a
role
i mean look he knows i'm a fan he knows
i watch him
he knows i'd love to work with him if
something's going to happen in the
future
it's going to happen yeah
oh dude yeah i think i think it's just a
terrible look if you say
that
if you were to do that i'm like oh no
man dude that's not the way you go about
it
but but uh yeah
[Laughter]
well i'm so happy that you know like
because because zach i call him zachary
uh he hit me up first
and um and i was like you know who you
really want to talk to
zechariah is uh tyrone so i'm so glad i
was able to get you this interview
tyrone you're welcome
i know you haven't said thank you yet
but you're welcome you're very much
welcome
i'm great i'm gonna return the favor if
you ever cast
me i'm asking to him to bring you in
i'm telling him right now but i'm
telling him look it's both of us
you give greg a three-minute interview
or nothing
i'm going to be the henchman that tyrone
punches up against one of zach center's
blood splattered walls
wearing a mask she would be prepared you
would do so much character building for
that
well dude i'm really happy for you
seriously this is um this is awesome
like you you i like i said at the top of
this video
uh before we start filming the reaction
like you've always been
like a passionate snyder verse a
supporter
whereas like me i was late to becoming a
passionate
not reversal i remember when you first
actually remember this now when you
first came out to l.a
you were you're like did you really not
like batman v super is one of the first
conversations you have with me
and and i know we like kind of like
debated a little bit about it
and uh so yeah it's just kind of funny
to be like yeah i'm late to that i
eventually grew to really loving that
movie whereas
you have always since day one been
hardcore so
like you haven't you absolutely deserved
this you absolutely earned it yeah
well better late than never better late
than never
it's always good to convert to the snow
that's justice right there you finally
came over to the right side
even i did even i did have to do yeah
that's true
much better when you get it you get it
all right man i'll let you go but thank
you dude
i'll let you know when this video is up
thank you man all right see you later
congrats again dude
bye hate that guy
god what a
about some interview yeah it's a good
question i would have personally liked
mullet superman
just going that extra mile i don't know
why he would have a beard and long hair
while he after he died you know but it
would have been cool looking yeah i
think justice league too
is is definitely a conversation that's
going to be like oh it hasn't
it says right now rotten tomatoes is way
higher than the jos
josta's cut and it's higher than his
other dc films that's
true this is going to do wild numbers
for um hbo max so i really do think that
and it's a damn good film you guys
decide for you guys to see it
we'll probably do a spoiler talk for it
i think uh maybe saturday
yeah saturday sounds like the best i
think people watch it thursday and
friday keep a look out for it
um but yeah i'm really happy for the guy
asked about the k-flip
i know because it does look like exactly
glider doesn't have away with those he's
got a great cape flap you know like the
reveal and i remember the man of steel
when he's first hovering over the
military when he shows up there in the
end like this shot from behind he has
this coming down it's like an opposing
figure it's a beautiful cape flap yeah
apes get a bad rap these days and zack
snyder's making him look good
yeah i think it's really cool how zach
is very much aware of uh
his fan base and such and how he does
connect like he connects with other
people like
i think even i'm like he's supposed to
be going if i'm not mistaken i heard an
announcement
geeks and gamers he's supposed to be
going on their stream
and geeks and gamers has been vocal
about how he like
he likes zack snyder's films but isn't a
fan of the direction he was taking
with the dceu films but he's still going
on the charity stream with him
so yeah i think hor or les zach sander
doesn't know that
he's just not learning this that's like
i'm not going on this
job leaving charity street outside i
won't do this for charity
yeah my ego's bigger than your charity
yeah unless you like my movies that's
true for me yeah this is exciting time
man i'm really happy i can't wait for
i can't wait for justice league to come
out it's gonna happen
believe it's gonna happen now tyrone did
a great job i just want to share this
reaction now
this is great thank you so much guys for
being here subscribe keep a look out for
our snyder cut announcement we'll
probably do a live stream spoiler talk
for you guys to chime in
get people to watch it for our movie
from thursday and friday come in on
saturday
four hour livestream for our live stream
incoming
catch you guys soon